bonjour à tous j'ai une voix beaucoup
plus graves que d'habitude car je suis
très malade sa santé grave dans plus d
habitude whedon est impressionné c'est
bon c'est une fille très heureux
aujourd'hui vidéo c'est top je suis un
peu ému après plusieurs semaines de
travaux c'est faux ça durait une semaine
mais je fais ce genre que c'était très
long etc
j'en ai souffert je vais vous montrer
mon nouveau décor et surtout de
l'endroit où je vais passer beaucoup de
temps cette année parce que au-delà du
décor il y aussi un espace pour écrire
un espace pour se poser et qui fait que
ses potes bref vous allez voir dans un
instant qu'est ce que c'est c'est quoi
ça ah c'est mon livre qui est dispo à la
fnac et sur un bateau nous et monique
c'est ouf
yes alors le des crabes je suis un peu
ému on y va john est le redis papa matin
sur inter ne donnons pas aux gens ce
qu'ils veulent tout de suite voir pense
à mon match times john on manipule on
est là pour manipuler tout ça nous
messieurs dames bienvenue dans ce
merveilleux espace de vie mais auteur et
moi-même pourront écrire et avoir des
réunions digne de ce nom sur une table
adéquat
on a mis du parquet vous l'avez remarqué
transition devait être pas mal j'ai fait
mettre du parquet parce que je trouve
c'est plus chaleureux mais qui en mode
valérie damidot je suis parti je suis
lancé le plus personne peut m'arrêter
nous avons ici une petite étagère que je
regarde régulièrement quand je regarde à
cet endroit c'est pour me rappeler à
quel point montréal est plus fort que
moi tekken et de ne plus jamais rejouer
avec lui quand je regarde à cet endroit
c'est pour me rappeler à quel point je
suis le boss qu à 10 millions d'abonnés
je suis clairement un monstre quoi ici
très important le mégaphone accessoires
favoris dont lucas est ici en bas mais
je sais qu'au cours mais que je passe
pour un [ __ ] d'alcoolique et écoutez
moi bien je vous promets je n'ai jamais
mis cette bouteille hiller qui a mis une
bouteille de champagne ici c'est vrai
c'est le moment non j'ai envie de
secouer j'ai jamais fait de ma vie à la
fin de la vidéo pourquoi j'ai des saint
john pour le voilà bien joué
[Musique]
et ici on a un petit espace pour se
poser et un jouet on va pas se mentir à
smash bros
regardez d'ailleurs il ya juste une
switch il n'y a rien d'autre ni ps4 et
xbox
ici c'est ce match pourquoi cette grande
télé pour qu'on voit bien son perso même
quand on joue à huit les joueurs de ce
match comprendront tout ça je fais
partie de cette catégorie de gens qui
mettent vu votre camp sur leur écran
c'est chaleureux savent avec le parquet
canapé en cuir c'est pas moi qui choisis
ce canapé j'ai aucune idée de la matière
et de tout mais on est vraiment pas mal
je suis atteint de la lande connectables
c'est à dire c'est une maladie très
grave tu découvres les langues connectés
et on achète beaucoup trop beaucoup trop
pour un seul homme ça ne sert à rien
d'en avoir autant je n'ai mis derrière
la télé derrière la figurine derrière le
beau tonnes de youtube tout en l'état
gère en bas de l'étagère derrière le
canapé
c'est une vraie maladie vous comprenez
il ya un argument qui fait que j'ai
acheté tout ça vous allez rire les
lumières bouge sur le rythme de votre
musique
vous allez voir franchement c'est pas
mal c'est 80% décevant et 20% pas mal on
y va c'est parti on dire voilà 500
balles pour ce moment alors juste avec
d'autres gens pris 2 pour remercier tous
ceux qui ont bossé pour l'aménagement du
bureau etc
si j'avais dû faire ça tout seul
j'aurais mis un an et le rendu serait
vraiment dégueulasse par rapport à là
pour vous prouver ça je veux montrer le
seul truc que j'ai fait c'est collé le
bouton qui contrôle toutes les lampes
il n'est pas droit et je suis très fier
pour être sincère avec vous l'ancien
décor j'étais trop content qu'on venait
de le faire ça allait parfaitement avec
ce que j'avais dans ma tête ma façon de
voir les choses à l'époque etc
mais sauf que dernièrement avons juste
avant qu'on change je n'étais pas très
content quand je venais j'étais un peu
j'allais dans une pièce qui me convient
pas et je trouve ça hyper important de
se sentir bien chez soi est aussi un
endroit où tu tapes surtout quand ça
concerne de la création même si je
l'idée serait drôle c'est cool quand
l'endroit où tu taft play est utile sans
bien psychologiquement tu es au top et
en fait tu as une créativité qui est
meilleur tu as envie de venir enfin bon
vous savez sûrement de quoi je parle
mais c'était vraiment important pour moi
de changer c'est le moment un peu
émotions de la vidéo le sol c'est mon
frère qui a bossé sur le décor qui a un
peu consul truc et c'est elle qui est
venue aussi faire certaines choses dont
vous allez voir tout ça dans un instant
bienvenue dans mon nouveau décor et là
vous êtes d'ailleurs c'est ça que vous
voulez voir c'est pas ça et vas tu peux
attendre la fin pour le mode time les
amis
c'est pas ce que vous pourriez [ __ ]
laissez moi il ya eu pas mal de trucs
ont changé au niveau du bureau mais il
ya aussi pas mal de trucs qui sont
restés je vais essayer de vous donner
aussi des vrais type ce conseil par
rapport au matériel vous avez pas besoin
d'avoir exactement le même matériel que
moi pour faire des vidéos pas du tout il
ya des trucs qui coûteront bien moins
cher et qui vous permettront de faire un
bon résultat quasiment pareil donc voilà
ça je voulais juste préciser ça mais est
ce que je vous ai parlé de ce magnifique
clavier logitech avec son doux coussin
il rendra vos prestations sur les jeux
vidéo bien meilleur visage par l'état
souris logitech sans fil avec un temps
de réponse quasi nul pour les procès
indiqué sur le dessous et attendez c'est
chiant une souris sans fil la recharge
et c'est énervant je parlais du tapis de
souris logitech qui permet à cette
dernière de se recharger tout seul en
étant simplement posé dessus un bon
gamer se doit d'entendre ses ennemis
arrivée et grâce au casque logitech pro
à
il est derrière à droite gbl tous été
payés par aucune marque pour cette vidéo
là par contre être encore avec do
logitech est un sponsor plus la chaîne
youtube est en gros il faut que quand
j'utilise un casque ce soit un logitech
voilà mais en vrai à mon avis sur le
matos même si du coup bah vous allez
vous dire que cet objectif
c'est très bien c'était un avis plutôt
courbe efficace après je suis pas
compliqué tant que ça fait de la lumière
et que ça fait ce week en appui je suis
satisfait pour le micro j'ai acheté un
no man tlm 103 il coûte 1000 euros et je
ne comprends toujours pas pourquoi
aurais-je est pris à eux mêmes parce que
quand on a fait des voix pour les courts
métrages en studio c'était ce micro là
et je trouve que nos voix était vraiment
vert sauf qu'en fait c'était pas dit au
micro était juste et au traitement de la
voix qui a eu derrière je suis vraiment
coup ok alors il est quand même un peu
mieux que celui que j'avais avant qui
était un haka gp 220 qui coûte je crois
dans les 150 euros comme le rhode mtn
qui veut c'est un très bon micro avec un
très bon rapport qualité prix dont je
vous conseille plutôt l'un de ces deux
là plutôt que celui ci voilà je vais pas
vous faire genre que c'est incroyable
prenez-ça n'ont clairement pas je vous
donne les prix et tout pour être
transparents et et vous donner des
conseils si ça vous plait pas bah bah
c'est trop tard pour moi j'aurais dû le
savoir avant de tourner aussi j'ai le
pied le rhode le fameux comment il
s'appelle déjà psa 1 tc bref trop
bizarre explique tout le monde a et
c'est le même que j'avais dans la
première vidéo cet homme qu'on a fait ya
trois ans et il marche toujours nickel
donc merci road pour cette qualité quand
même au niveau de la caméra elle n'est
pas là parce que c'est john qui est en
train de films actuellement avec dans
ses mains c'est un sony à 7s de avec un
objectif 1 16 35 de chez dice qui est
dessus alors pareil c'est une caméra que
beaucoup de gens ton avec je sais que ma
claque ait au thon avec aussi cyprien
aussi sur bigorre de coquillages on
tourne aussi avec c'est vraiment une
bonne caméra polyvalente qui est hyper
bien mais elle est aussi chère si vous
avez un budget plus petit a le chic et
le sony ericsson qui est pas mal c'est
d'ailleurs avec cette caméra
actuellement que je filme mais live ça
coûte moins cher que cet appareil là
c'est plus petit plus compact pour
développe aussi c'est très cool un bon
appareil que j'aime beaucoup et je ne
saurais pas vous conseillez d'autres
marques parce que j'ai toujours eu
quasiment que du sony à l'époque j'avais
un le fameux canon 600d mais je suppose
qu'il est complètement démodée ouais il
est un peu dépassée enfin mois après
pour vous faire un avis le mieux c'est
d'aller sur des forums etc
selon votre budget il ya vraiment ça
peut ça peut tout changer quoi donc moi
ma caméra elle est reliée à un retour
blackmagic que je redis avec un câble
hdmi et en fait ça permet de faire
sauter la limite de temps qu'il ya sur
ces caméras là on peut faire que des
rushes de 25 minutes sauf que quand à la
tête dans un casque verts battus voit
pas que ça a coupé au bout de 25 minutes
et tu vois pas le temps passer donc tbw
alors au niveau du bureau c'est le
premier vrai bureau
trop stylé que j'ai vraiment de toute ma
vie donc je suis hyper content pourquoi
pour une chose extrêmement simple c'est
que ici on a des boutons et en fait on
peu près réglé une position du bureau
qui permet tout simplement de changer sa
hauteur agréable alors ça peut vous
paraître tout qu'on est anodin mais pour
certaines vidéos notamment celles on est
plusieurs on peut beaucoup plus bouger
dans l'espace et tout dans le cadre que
quand on est assis vous l'avez vu avec
deux buts fut au lit ou même mcfly tôt
quand ils plaçaient sur ma chaîne
c'était toujours un peu galère il ya
toujours un mec qui est quasiment hors
champ matin c'était vraiment une tannée
être debout comme on fait sur peu comme
un coquillage c'est la liberté
à plusieurs c'est vraiment bien et même
seul je trouve ça il ya un autre mood
sur le tournage et c'est chouette ça
peut vous paraître vraiment con mais
c'est genre de petites nouveautés qui
donne l'impression que l'on reprend un
peu à zéro les vidéos que l'on met un
pas dans l'inconnu dans un nouveau truc
alors que c'est tout comme quoi c'est
juste passé de assis à deux bouts voilà
pour le bureau qui est la grosse
nouveauté moi perso c'est le truc qui me
fait kiffer pour retourner maintenant
c'est tournez debout quoi vous parlez de
l'écran à horus 27 pouces 144 r c'est
une résolution de 2 cas avec une dalle
du ps je crois pas à horrues sponsorise
ma chaîne twitch cette année et du coup
il va envoyer un peu de stuff
pour être franc avec vous je viens de
recevoir jours donc je peux pas vous
dire il est bien il est pas bien j'en
serais [ __ ] de rien et mon deuxième
écran en fait je devais recevoir 2 à
horus et j'en ai reçu qu'un sur les deux
pour le moment et donc mon deuxième
c'est mon ancien écran que je vais
changer c'est un 24 pouces et demi je
crois de la marque 24 pouces et demi
c'est un ben cul voilà ça j'avais oublié
je sais plus la référence mais pour les
références exactes elles seront en
descriptions et ses 1 241 parce qu'en
fait je pensais qu'en en ayant plus
images par seconde
meilleur jeu ça n'a pas du tout rendu
mais et la deuxième chose dont je suis
très content et que sina une grosse
nouveauté pour moi et ça sera dans
toutes les vidéos c'est les lumières du
studio avant j'avais deux spots qui
étaient sur pied et qui était un peu
approximatif j'en avais rajouter un
troisième pour mieux éclairer la porte
fin c'était un peu foireux comme
installation et je dépends des beaucoup
du coût de la fenêtre qu'il ya juste là
et je voulais un set up light un peu
plus fixe parce que mine de rien la
lumière c'est hyper important pour avoir
une belle image et moi mon image elle
était très hasardeuse des fois elle
était très jours des fois très bleu
alors clément il rattrape et saâles et à
l'eau comme il pouvait mais c'était très
irrégulier donc on a installé quatre
lumières ici une quelqu'un de décors de
qu'éclaire mois et le décor est une car
en contre qui forment sa silhouette en
vrai les spots comme ça ça coûte assez
cher ce que je vous conseille de prendre
c'est ce que j'ai pour mon 7e place
c'est juste des petits l'aide panel des
petits lie panel il y en a sur amazon
pourquoi 50 euros et ça éclaire très
bien donc l' avantage de tout ça c'est
que c'est relié à l'ipad là et je peux
comprendre toutes les lumières grâce à
ça je peux diminuer ou augmenter les
lumières comme ça ce qui est cool c'est
que je vais pouvoir créer des ambiances
en fonction de ce que je tourne là c'est
l'ambiance un peu quand je tourne un
truc quelconque et j'ai créé une
ambiance pour quand je fais un thread
horreur up et c'est plus sombre et la
lumière rencontre sûrement et rouge
aussi mais je crois que j'ai un problème
avec l'élan pour général j'ai un
problème
j'adore la lumière elle suit un groupe
kéké avec son et lumière est en tout cas
maintenant je peux tout contrôler grâce
à l'ipad alors qu'avant je devais
baisser et appuyé sur deux boutons et
franchement c'est scandaleux qu au
niveau du set-up audio je vous ai parlé
du micro c'est un micro xlr donc il faut
une carte sont pour le relier à son pc
j'ai rien changé sur ça mais bon je le
redis au cas où j'ai là phocuswright de
i2 voilà que tout le monde ait fait très
bien le tap et j'ai aussi ici un ampli
que j'ai pas changé non plus question
clé ça à quoi il sert à compresser ma
voix c'est à dire que quand je crie ça
ne sature pas et ça vous détruit pas les
oreilles c'est le sens qui est super
acide leçon 2
[Musique]
il sert juste à ça mais dans mon cas
c'est très vital qu'est ce qui va
manquer à la chaise peut-être importante
j'ai pas du tout une chaise de gamer
parce que je trouve qu'en vidéo c'est un
peu trop imposants j'en ai eu pour mon
set up live à 8 h précises
en fait je dit c'est ta plaque parce que
c'est pas ici du tout que je fais mais
là c'est vraiment chez moi ça c'est une
chaise qui étaient vendus par jarvis
ceux qui font le bureau je n'ai aucune
idée de la référence mais c'est une
bonne chose
écoute je les ai même pas utiliser
encore c'est horrible je sais comme
l'écran je peux pas vous dire mais je
suppose qu'elle est bien elle est
confortable je crois que j'ai tout dit à
le pcg pas parler du pc incroyable va
écouter grosse nouveauté c'est le même
qu'il ya trois ans rien n'a changé je
crois que cette gtx nvidia 1080 le
processeur je mettrai tous ces détails
là en descriptions mais voilà le pc n'a
pas bougé pour la simple et bonne raison
que je fais de moins en moins de gaming
et que pour lire des ce raid et regarder
des vidéos en ce film en soi même il n'y
a pas besoin d'une machine de guerre ça
a des avantages 1 c'est un escroc bon
cette fois je crois qu'on est bon parce
qu'on passe à oui oui les amis je suis
un peu ému j'espère que ça va vous
plaire en tout cas moi ça me plaît et
c'est le plus important
comme j'ai expliqué se sentir bien dans
l'endroit on tourne le voici
[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le constater de très
grands artistes sont venus dessinée sur
le mur l'un des deux est d'ailleurs le
meilleur illustrateur de paris puisque
je dis ça parce qu'il s'agit de mon
frère
oui et le second est l'un des meilleurs
stats war de paris aussi s'appelle la
mine qui ce que je dis ça parce que
c'est le meilleur ami mon frère
oui l'idée c'était de mettre des objets
et de dessiner des trucs en rapport avec
l'objet au tour sur le mur à même le mur
vous venez dans les vidéos ça est plus
vraiment la forme de chaque objet là au
moins ça change un peu ça mais dans une
vraie ambiance un peu adulte et où je
trouve ça vraiment cool en vrai c'est
super stylé ce qu'ils ont fait je trouve
ça trop cool d'avoir ces petites touches
artistique que je ne serai pas du tout
faire moi-même alors voilà bravo et
bravo tu ce qui allait faire ça c'est
vraiment fou la petite plante la petite
figurine theraform mars
vous parlez de tout mais soumet art
figurines qui existentiellement 600
exemplaires ils font les plus belles
figurines possible surtout les animés
japonais il imaginable
j'ai bien bougé la figurine et le fond
ne colle plus du tout avec cette
dernière je vais devoir retrouver la
position dans laquelle elle était est-ce
que je rate complètement ma journée
oui ici on a une petite map monde je
trouve ça cool j'adore voyager j'adore
découvrir des cultures et dans
l'adversité donc est ici c'est un masque
japonais que j'ai acheté à hassaï south
japon ceux qui connaissent les quartiers
traditionnels de tokyo il ya le gros
temple voilà on a mis sous cloche ou une
raison inconnue
on trouvait ça cool tout n'a pas une
explication je suis désolé et surtout
j'ai remis le fameux dwayne johnson et
le fameux jackie chan ils sont posés sur
l'étagère des rejets et même pas
nettoyées on peut voir qu'ils sont
absolument dégueulasse et un petit
instrument de musique j'essaie de mettre
un peu à la musique peu à peu c'est une
passion que j'ai dans ce crime
j'aime un thé et là en fait le tableau
de le seul truc qui va bouger c'est ça
en fait ce sera un tableau un tout petit
peu plus grand de l'illustration que mon
frère a fait pour ma chaîne la bannière
de ma chaîne youtube qui ressemble à ça
et en gros il y aura un tableau de 50 cm
sur 50 qui sera ici mais en attendant je
me suis là parce que je le trouve
vraiment cool je l'avais acheté à venise
et je trouve qu'il est très sympa
derrière le tableau tu dis aux gens qui
intrigue parce que j'étais et montrer ce
qu'il y avait derrière
ok vous avez quoi deviner ce qu'il ya
derrière le tableau a laissé un dessin
sur un mur ce sera le secret de mon
décor ont créé un mythe jeu le
révèlerait un jour dans un mois un an
deux ans on sait pas essayer de deviner
ce que c'est
vous pouvez pas trois têtes c'est un
truc tout con et l'appareil la petite
île sur la porte on savait pas quoi
marquer pourquoi mar crêpa porte sur la
porte et la petite touch il ya quand
même un truc que moi j'ai imaginé dans
ce décor c'est quoi devinez mais oui la
réponse des la lèvre ça c'est la touch
de l'uqar à des cas la lumière l'ucal
kikoo est passée par là voilà j'espère
vraiment que ça va vous plaire je sais
que ça va vous brusquer moi aussi ça m'a
boosté au début j'étais un mode à c'est
tellement un changement radical que
c'est une nouveauté qui fait un peu peur
et surtout je suis très nostalgique
j'ai vécu tellement nos mandants le sien
des corps tellement de trucs incroyables
et puis c'était surtout la première fois
dans l'ancien décor que je tournais
ailleurs que chez moi mes vidéos que
j'avais un affect particulier mais là
c'est vraiment une page qui se tourne
je suis un peu ému mais je suis aussi
très malade du coup peut-être qu'il faut
terminer cette vidéo je vous remercie
dans toutes ces années et j'espère que
cette année on va faire de trop bonne
vidéo ensemble le mot d'ordre cette
année c'est je me fait kiffer su que je
fais ce que j'ai envie de faire voilà ce
avec une petite émotion que nous
arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo on se
retrouve très vite dans une prochaine à
cet endroit du coup à bientôt et merci
c'est grâce à vous que j'ai pu faire le
décor un peu de mes rêves
parce que mine de rien ça coûtait
l'argent d'acheter ce truc de pintes de
mètres du parquet et d'acheter les trucs
de faire venir les gens pour graffer et
j'ai pu le faire donc merci à vous une
fois de plus parce que s'engouffrer
jamais pu le faire elle est allée dans
une prochaine vidéo
ciao les gens gros bisous
j'ai dit gros bisous on en est là
[Musique]
g